[Musique]
[Musique
] Personnellement, je suis consterné que le
président novice Mike Pence ait rejeté notre cabine
McMurdo à propos de ce qui est une attaque contre l'
analyste afghan qui n'arrête pas de publier son
propre rapport dans le New York Times News
[Musique]
Des  acquisition donc phénomène dans PB
Apollo New York Times risotto Muskoka
Los Cabos occasionnellement Alamos vieil
américain Afghanistan témoignage sur Amazon
ou CGI deux adjoints employé des
ambassadeurs a Washington Rondo CC de
correo de force déformation méthodologie
la vie des Eaux the New York Times musique
honk Rizzuto et
Utilisation aléatoire compétente américaine du postulat concret
Obligation fédérale américaine à un aperçu irrationnel
pour le yen promotionnel afin de tirer parti
des sources minérales diplomatiques de la hausse
[Musique]